[Music]
if i said
should we invest in the science of aging
to help people
live healthier longer lives maybe some
people would say yes and some people
would say no
but if i said should we invest in
fighting cancer
or dementia or heart disease probably
everybody would say yes
but all three of those and so many other
diseases are correlating with aging and
fighting
each manifestation of aging is like
playing whack-a-mole one thing doesn't
get you
the other thing will and so it certainly
makes sense at least to me
that we should try to address the
underlying
biology of aging
human life expectancy is getting longer
in 1910 humans in the united states
were only expected to live 40 to
50 years now
in just over a century we've nearly
doubled that with an average lifespan
of almost 80 years and
according to futurist jamie metzel we're
working on technology to extend that
even further there's a lot of really
exciting work
about sequencing genome sequencing
people who
live into their hundreds to see which is
the case
are there genetic differences between
those kinds of people and everybody else
and genes and struct cells to make
proteins so what are their genes
instructing their cells to do and can we
mimic those kinds of outcomes for uh for
everybody else
if we could mimic that for our entire
population
could we stop older generations from
dying off
would our planet become crowded with
people
how would family dynamics be changed
and how could our health care system
become overwhelmed
before we get to the consequences of
indefinitely
extending our lifespans let's take a
look at
how we would do it in the first place
in just over 100 years we've
considerably expanded the average human
life expectancy
by improving sanitation workplace safety
and most importantly healthcare
we've developed treatments for
life-threatening injuries and
we've eradicated some of the world's
deadliest diseases
but if we want to extend our lifespans
any further
we'll need to tackle the biggest threat
to our bodies
aging but first we need to understand
what aging is and there have been some
incredible
incredible work and great progress in
just understanding the basic
mechanisms of aging and there's even a
debate raging about is aging
one comprehensive thing or is it a bunch
of of different
parts uh different systems within the
human body that are aging at different
rates which is important because
you don't want to kind of have an
immortal one kind of cell and then
mortal other kind of cell because you'll
just be equally equally dead
so there's some really exciting science
though about understanding well how can
we
basically shift the way our bodies
function
the way our cells function from growth
mode into repair mode how do we put
ourselves
into kind of the equivalent of screen
saver
well it's already begun and it's all
thanks to something called
crispr crispr stands for clustered
regularly interspaced short palindromic
repeats
never heard of it yeah me neither
so let's head back to our resident
expert jamie metzel to explain it
it's an ability um to to cut and paste
like on microsoft word
the genome the genome is the source code
of
life and you can cut it to turn off a
gene
you can add genetic material and that
is what allows us to to rewrite genetic
code having said that
um genetic code is incredibly complex
and so people shouldn't imagine that we
can just
rewrite everything we're in the
beginning of the genome editing
revolution but it's moving really
quickly
so if we can start editing out the genes
that cause us the most problems then
one day we could theoretically live in a
world where
no one ever dies of old age wouldn't
that be great
well don't get too excited because in
reality
it might not be that simple let's look
at the pros and cons and
then we'll see if you still think it's a
good idea
the first pro is pretty obvious we
wouldn't lose as many of our loved ones
everyone would be able to live alongside
generations of their
descendants families would have
lots of support because parents could
have many
different grandparents
great-grandparents
great-great-grandparents and more to
help
raise new children if we all lived
forever
people might care more about the future
meaning that issues like climate change
would be more important to older people
because
they would be alive for the effects
but as jamie said aging is a complicated
mix of things and
we won't be able to get rid of all the
bad things at once
even if we get rid of some of the
deadliest aspects of aging
we might still have to deal with
deteriorating bones
muscles and minds
and that brings us to the cons
sure we'd all live longer but what good
is that if we're suffering past a
certain age
the older people get the more care they
would need
we might not need hospitals as much but
care facilities for older people would
quickly be overwhelmed eventually we
would reproduce to the point that we
would surpass the limits of food
supplies and other resources
at this point there might be some push
to enforce birth control
and that likely wouldn't go over well
cities would become overcrowded and
civil unrest may be more prevalent
and just to be even more of a downer
this is based on the idea of our entire
planet
collectively gaining access to this
technology but
realistically that's not how it would
happen
more developed wealthier nations would
likely have access to this technology
first so
they'd have a head start in building a
population
of superhumans and that could be
dangerous for
international relations the question for
us
is how do we use this technology wisely
and how do we use it wisely in ways
that don't divide populations the way
that's ha
that's completely happened in the past i
mean when europe
had faster technological advancement
than other countries in the world they
use that
to colonize and kill people
all around the world and that was that
that divide if we don't want that
we just need to make sure that our most
sacred
values guide the application of our most
powerful technologies
[Music]
so regardless of whether or not you
think this is a good idea
one thing seems clear if we are going to
pursue some
level of immortality then
we need a plan for everything that comes
with it
and maybe that plan should involve some
of us
relocating to our neighboring red planet
but that's a story for another
what if